my segment is on increasing
explosiveness and training to maximize
jump height in particular but probably
most sort of explosive movements in
general
um
and uh yeah the the one weird trick that
I'm going to talk about is training with
accommodating resistance or for for
people who haven't spent much time with
the West Side barbell parlance just
training with bands or chains so
um just just for some very very basic
background for people who have not
trained with bands or chains before
aren't very familiar with accommodating
resistance uh basically it's just a
different way to add resistance to a
variety of exercises but primarily what
I'm thinking about here is barbell
exercises Beyond just putting more
plates on the bar uh and so when you add
plates on the bar you know the barbell
is 45 pounds you slap some 45s on now
it's 135 pounds and uh that's just due
to gravity which is pulling straight
down all the time and whatever you
whatever lift you do uh at all points in
the range of motion there will be 135
pounds of resistance you have to
overcome that's that's just what the
weight is with accommodating resistance
uh if you hang some like thick elastic
rubber bands Over the Bar those bands
behave as a hooke's law spring wood or
in other words as they're stretched the
resistance they provide increases
linearly so at the bottom of a squat for
example the bands might provide 40
pounds of resistance and at the top they
may provide 80 pounds of resistance and
right in the middle guess what they'd
provide 60 pounds of resistance so it
allows for variable resistance
throughout the range of motion and
chains behave similar similarly you can
hang chains from the bar generally off
of a smaller chain so that when you're
at the bottom of a lift most of the
chains are on the ground and then at the
top of the lift most of the chains are
off of the ground so for example if you
put 100 pounds of chains on the bar at
say the bottom of a bench press maybe
you're feeling 250 pounds with all of
the chains on the ground and and then
when you lock it out you're now filling
350 pounds because those hundred pounds
of chains have come off of the ground
um
so yeah with with accommodating
resistance you can vary the amount of
resistance you're dealing with
throughout the range of motion and in
particular it makes the lifts a little
bit easier at the bottom a little bit
harder at the top uh Eric have you ever
done much or any training with bands or
chains oh hell yeah hell yeah I mean
what what's your what's your go-to or
what's your favorite it kind of it
didn't really matter dude uh so when I
first got into
um coaching
um like like you know working as a
strength coach I was working with a a
wrestling team and a football team and I
had all the gym access I could ever want
and it was a really well equipped gym I
would go in there I was you know 18 19
20 years old and just put chains on
literally everything because it was so
badass oh absolutely dips pull-ups just
throwing like could have easily used any
other mode of resistance but I was like
no dude put the chain around my neck
yeah uh but yeah I would do
um you know oh rack chins are kind of
like you know inverted body weight rows
with some chains I would do uh bench
press with chains I would just any
excuse to get them in the mix I would
use it yeah that's that's completely
valid so I I also love chains I
personally don't like bands all that
much
um
not because I think they're ineffective
I just I just don't like how they make
lifts feel but that and they're to me
they were always a pain in the ass to
set up I I agree it's hard to find two
bands that have like the exact same
amount of resistance so the bar feels
like a little bit uneven
um but anyway yeah love chains anything
with chains they're one they're loud and
I like I like things that are loud uh
you're lifting like you're working out
makes you sound like Jacob Marley which
is very cool uh one of one of the best
characters in in all of fiction and
literature
um
and yeah like I I really enjoy the way
they make most most strength curves feel
um but yeah so that's that's what we're
going to be talking about here for for
the purpose not so much of trying to
maximize strength gains but trying to
maximize gains in Explosive Performance
and like I said specifically jump height
so
I I actually got in trouble uh couple
months ago uh when talking about
accommodating resistance I was on Dave
Tate's table Talk podcast and this topic
came up
um and I mentioned that like hey the the
research tends to suggest that for
specifically maximizing gains in raw
strength like say trying to maximize
gains in barbell squat one rep max or
barbell bench press one rep max uh
training with accommodating resistance
does seem to be effective for strength
gains but doesn't seem to be more
effective than just training with
straight weight
um which in most uh sectors of the
powerlifting Community is is a pretty
uncontroversial opinion
um but there are a lot of like big time
old school West Side fans in in the
table talk audience uh they didn't
particularly like that perspective which
is totally fair uh but I will note that
the that the research and also just like
the training practices of the current
best raw power lifters on the planet
agree with me so on the on the power
lifters side I mean there are a ton of
extremely strong raw power lifters out
there uh and if you stalk them on social
media to see how they train you just
don't see that many folks training with
bands or chains a ton anymore again
specifically for for raw power lifting
accommodating resistance for
specifically strength development does
make a lot of sense for equipped lifting
because it allows you to experience a
strength curve but or like a resistance
curve that is a little more similar to
what you'd be dealing with with equipped
power lifting because like a bench shirt
squat suit helps you more at the bottom
of the lift than the top of the lift so
if you don't want to have to deal with
getting into all of your gear but you
still want a similar uh training
experience you can set up accommodating
resistance to kind of mimic that but for
raw lifting
um yeah I mean you just don't see that
many top raw lifters doing a ton of
training with bands or chains these days
and on the research side of things uh in
2015 there was a meta-analysis published
by Soria Gila and colleagues uh
suggesting that training with
accommodating resistance did in fact
improve strength gains to a larger
extent than training with straight
weight but then in 2018 another group of
researchers led by dos Santos
um
like I I think these I think these folks
were just planning on doing a study uh
like looking at the effects of of bands
or chains on strength development so
they're they're like okay let's kind of
get our feet wet in this research let's
pull up this meta-analysis see what it
found and then they started looking
through the meta-analysis and said I
think they may have accidentally
miscalculated some of these effect sizes
so they wrote in and said hey I think
there were some errors here uh and and
to the credit of Soria Gila and
colleagues
um they looked back and said yep you got
us like we we made a mistake uh so that
that has now been updated and the the
pooled effect is like yeah straight
weight is effective bands and chains are
effective uh training with accommodating
resistance doesn't seem to be more
effective than just training with
straight weight though it does still
work
um do you think that might be the only
exercise science meta with an error
foreign
don't want to get too far off topic but
we we should probably talk about that
that paper we will at some point but for
people that are listening we won't get
into it but there's there was a paper I
think last week or the week before that
was published indicating they're like
yeah we went through a bunch of metas
and like exercising Sports Science I
think they said 85 percent had a
statistical error at least one yeah yeah
uh which is
both knots that was very unsurprising to
us yeah um but I think it would be
surprising to a lot of people but yeah
it's certainly not what you'd like to
see right yeah but anyway I'm sorry to
interrupt with that tangent but but yeah
so uh training with accommodating
resistance in terms of one rep max raw
strength development doesn't seem to be
all that beneficial again it's good it
works fine it just doesn't seem to work
better than training with straight
weight uh and there's good good reason
to kind of suspect that it wouldn't be
better than straight weight and and the
reason for that
is just for most exercises if you're
doing a one rep max specifically barbell
lifts generally
you're not your your strength your one
rep max isn't going to be limited by how
strong you are through the entire range
of motion it's limited by how strong you
are through the very weakest point in
the range of motion which is usually
pretty early on in the concentric phase
or near the bottom of most lifts
um and in fact it's it's even earlier on
than I think a lot of people realize
most people assume the weakest point in
say a squad or a bench press is when the
bar is moving the slowest but it's
actually not it's when the bar is
decelerating because force is mass times
acceleration and so if acceleration is
negative that means there's less Force
output so if you're like if the bar is
still like moving at the same relatively
slow velocity that means the force
you're exerting is uh either equal to or
greater than the load on the barbell if
the bar is actively decelerating that
means at that moment in time you're
exerting less Force than the force being
exerted by the bar Bell uh so yeah like
the weakest point in the lift is even
before like what is commonly defined as
the sticking point so it's it's low down
there that's that's where your weakest
in most lifts and so that's what's
determining performance and the way that
uh the way that bands and chains work
it's like I mentioned before a band
stretches as you go up more chains come
off the ground as you go up so it makes
the lift harder near the top of the lift
which is totally fine but like generally
that's not the part of the range of
motion that's going to dictate what your
one rep max is it's more about can you
create enough Force there at the bottom
of the lift or you're the weakest
um
and so like yeah I mean there there's
every reason to think that training with
bands and chains are probably better for
building strength through the top part
of the lift than training with straight
weight would be but that's not going to
influence one rep max strength all that
much and training with both straight
weight and accommodating resistance
should be equally efficacious for
increasing strength at the bottom of the
lift like as long as you get the loading
right so the those results I think are
are pretty intuitive
um
so yeah that's that's not all that
surprising but with Explosive
Performance the calculus is a little bit
different and and this is where we're
getting into like the actual thrust of
this segment so with Explosive
Performance it's it's a completely
different ball game because it's not
about how strong you are through the
very weakest point in the lift for
something like jumping it's about how
much force can you put through the
ground for the entire duration of the
time your feet are on the ground and so
if you're getting a lot of velocity
going your feet aren't going to be on
the ground very long
um you know you drop down Boop pop right
back up pretty quick and so for that
short period of time for the entire
duration of the time your feet are on
the ground you need to be putting as
much force through the floor as possible
to accelerate your center of mass and as
soon as your feet hit leave the ground
the velocity your center of mass has at
that point of takeoff will directly
determine how high you're going to jump
um because you you are no longer putting
more Force into the floor therefore an
upward force on yourself as soon as your
feet leave the ground gravity takes over
and your takeoff velocity just like
one-to-one determines how high you're
going to jump and so you need to
accelerate as much as possible during
that entire time of during that entire
time span you have available to you and
therefore strength and power output
through that entire range of motion is
now very very important like if you can
exert a lot of force in deep knee and
hip flexion that's cool but if you can
also exert a lot of force with very
little knee and hip flexion right before
takeoff that is equally beneficial so
essentially if if there are two people
who have Who weigh the exact same amount
they have like similar fiber types like
you you equate everything between these
two individuals and they squat the same
amount through a full range of motion
but one of them squats way more or for
like a half squad or quarter squat than
the other one does you should expect
that individual with the higher half
Squat and quarter Squat and same full
squat to jump higher than the other
person because they have similar Force
output through that weak part of the
range of motion but through the stronger
part of the range of motion that second
individual is stronger can exert more
force uh Etc
and so
as I mentioned before a benefit of of
training with accommodating resistance
is you can better match the resistance
curve of an exercise with your natural
strength curve so you know for example
if you can bench press
225 pounds or like 100 kilos that
basically means that you can exert about
I'm I'm going to use kilos as a force
measurement I realize they're not but
you get the point that means you can
exert about 100 kilos of force where
you're the weakest but at the top maybe
you can exert 120 kilos of Force if
you're just training with a barbell
you're stuck with 100 kilos you can't go
heavier than that you'd fail the lift uh
with bands or chains on the other hand
you could potentially set it up to where
you know maybe you have 90 kilos on the
bar and 20 kilos in bands and chains or
something like that it's 90 kilos at the
bottom it's a little bit easier but then
it's 110 kilos at the top so it's it's
matching that it's matching the
resistance curve of the lift to your
natural strength curve a little bit
better so even though that's not going
to be extra beneficial for improving
your one rep max that probably will be
extra beneficial for increasing strength
throughout that entire range of motion
uh and and if you're watching on YouTube
um there there's a figure that we can
Flash up on the screen now that that
kind of illustrates how this works how
with accommodating resistance you can
make sure that that the lifts you're
doing are
challenging through a larger relative
proportion of the entire range of motion
you're training through and so for that
purpose just kind of on an a priori
basis you should expect that training
with accommodating resistance should be
better for improving Explosive
Performance and in fact that is what we
see when we look at the literature and
I'll also note it's it's a little
surprising how little research there is
on this topic
um just because a lot of times practical
application guides research to some
extent like there's a bit of a give and
take like research guides practical
application and practical application
guides research if there are a lot of
coaches doing something specific in the
gym with their athletes some of those
athletes are going to become Master
students in exercise science and realize
like hey the stuff that my coaches were
doing uh I don't think there's research
on that I'm going to do that as a
master's project so there's kind of that
feedback loop
um and bands and chains are just you
know it from a quote unquote in the
trenches perspective are used pretty
frequently for for training athletes at
all levels of sport from uh like you're
not going to see them in many high
school weight rooms but like training
facilities that specialize in training
high school athletes like off the clock
or out of school will often use bands
and chains uh plenty of college weight
rooms use bands and chains for a lot of
stuff like you mentioned before
um so yeah this is a pretty common thing
in practice but I was only able to find
four particular studies
um that have examined uh this so
comparing training with straight weight
versus training with bands or chains and
all of these studies use bands
um on uh gains and Explosive Performance
and in particularly jump height here so
uh to start with a study by She and
colleagues Shi and as a note mention
this every time all of the studies I
cite will be linked in the show notes so
starting with a study by She and
colleagues
um the subjects in the study were
Collegiate basketball players who uh
were were pretty well trained to start
with as far as Collegiate basketball
players go uh average one rep max Squad
was like 125 kilos which for tall
[ __ ] like that's not bad
um and they they completed an eight-week
training program one group just trained
with straight weights the other group
trained with a combination of straight
weights and bands uh and the the
resistance provided by the bands in the
band group was equal to 35 of 1rm at the
top of the lift and very very little at
the bottom of the lift
um so the amount of load on the bar that
was replaced was equal to about about 17
percent of one RM to equalize average
loading between the two groups so just
to illustrate if a subject had a 200
kilo Squat and I'm just using that to to
make the numbers easy
um so let's say a subject had a 200 kilo
Squat and in a particular workout
they're going to be training with 80 of
1rm so that's 160 kilos so in the group
that was just training with straight
weight you would just do reps with 160
kilos in the band group in this
particular study uh what they would
first do is remove
um
uh that they would add an amount of
bands that was equal to 35 of 1rm which
in this case would be 70 kilos 200 times
0.35 about 70. uh and then they would
um replace uh a portion of that so in
effect
um
like you would want it to be an average
of 160 kilos throughout the entire uh
portion of the lift so it would be
um I think they would put
125 yeah so it would be 125 kilos on the
bar plus the 70 kilos of bands so it'd
be like 125 at the bottom 195 at the top
average out to 160. so that like I did a
poor job explaining that but that that's
what they did hopefully hopefully that
makes sense
um so yeah they train like that for
eight weeks uh and ultimately squatting
with bands and squatting with straight
weight as one would expect from the rest
of the literature uh led to similar
increases in one RM squat strength which
again is what what we should expect
um but squatting with the bands did lead
to larger increases in squat jump
Improvement and counter movement jump
Improvement so it was like 21 1.4
percent versus 12.9 percent for squat
jump and 12.9 versus 5.6 for counter
movement jump oh but the p-value was
.056 so that doesn't really I mean it's
not below 0.05 makes you think wow well
okay let's just go with squat Jump Then
which was a p of 0.008 I'm being a smart
ass obviously I I don't subscribe to
that nitpicking uh with regards to P
values
yeah 12.9 percent is uh bigger than 5.6
percent I I agree with that assessment
um okay so so that was uh the first
study there were two more that had
broadly similar results so one was by
katushabe and Kramer and the other was
by joy and colleagues in the study by
katushabe and Kramer uh the subjects
were male soccer players they trained
for six weeks
um again one group with bands one group
with straight weights they found that
squatting with bands led to at least
nominally larger uh increases in Jump
height than training with straight
weight so about 2.67 centimeters versus
about 1.38 and then in the study by joy
and colleagues uh the subjects were
again Collegiate basketball players uh
completing a five-week training program
one group squatting with a combination
of bands and straight weights the other
group uh just squatting with straight
weight
um and they looked at two measures of a
vertical jump performance they measured
vertical jump height on both a force
plate so like using an equation to
estimate
um like how much like how high people
jumped from their ground reaction forces
during the actual jumping movement and
then also just a more direct assessment
of jump height using a vertek and if
memory serves in the study the vertek
jump height Improvement there was a
nominal difference between groups so it
was like a 6.3 percent increase in the
band group versus like a 4.1 percent
increase in the straight weight group I
don't think that was a statistically
significant difference and then for the
the force plate assessment uh it was
like plus 7.5 percent in the band group
and like minus 1.8 percent uh in the
straight weight group and if memory
serves that was a statistically
significant difference but like I said
all like all of the the nominal
differences lean lean in favor of of
squatting with bands and all of these
studies uh however the fourth study uh
by Anderson and colleagues in this
little body of literature uh did come to
different results so uh the subjects in
that study were trained women they
completed 10 weeks of training again one
group squatting with bands uh or a
combination of bands and straight
weights and the other group uh just
squatting with straight weight and they
assessed counter movement jump height
um with uh
like like basically different knee
angles to start with so like how far you
would descend uh for the counter
movement before jumping back up so they
looked at kind of like a a two kind of
normal uh ranges of motion for jump so
through 60 and 90 degrees of knee
flexion that's around how much most
people would Flex their knees before a
jump and then they also looked at like
what if you just did a really really
deep counter movement before you jumped
um so down to about 120 degrees of knee
flexion and what they found is that at
least in terms of nominal differences
gains in Jump height at 60 degrees of
knee flexion were pretty similar uh
between the two training approaches uh
leaned slightly in favor of squatting
with bands but then at 90 degrees and
120 degrees those nominal differences
leaned in favor of squatting with
straight weight so essentially we have
three studies that tend to find benefits
in favor of training with accommodating
resistance and we have one study that
found at least a deeper levels of knee
flexion some some benefits maybe of
squatting with straight weight so what
could potentially explain the the
different results between these three
studies and I think the biggest
difference is just how much of the total
resistance came from bands so in the
three studies that tended to find
benefits of squatting with bands the
ones by she joy and catashabe and Kramer
the bands replaced about 15 to 20
percent of the total load on the bar
with the total band resistance equaling
about 30 to 40 percent of one RM at the
top
um
and for the Anderson study the the total
band tension used and therefore the
amount of actual weight replaced by
bands was like twice that large so it
was a a relatively enormous amount of
band tension used in that study so like
that that kind of makes sense
intuitively right so in the Anderson
study they found that through deeper
levels of knee flexion squatting with a
ton of band tension maybe wasn't great
for improving jump height but if you
have a ton of band tension on the bar
effectively you're just making the very
bottom of the lift very easy so what you
should be going for and I think what
three of the four studies in this area
accomplished is with accommodating
resistance instead of a kind of
traditional strength curve or resistance
curve you'd see with straight weight
where the bottom of the lift is hard and
the top is easy what you want to do with
the amount of accommodating resistance
you use is you basically want want the
entire lift to be similarly challenging
throughout you want the bottom to be
challenging you want the top to be
challenging train that entire range of
motion I think what happened in the
Anderson study is they used so much band
tension they inverted that typical
resistance curve where instead of now
being hard at the bottom and easy at the
top I think they just made it very easy
at the bottom and hard at the top so
there was less transference to jump
height at deeper degrees of knee flexion
um
so yeah uh overall the this uh body of
literature and also just kind of the the
logical reasoning I I laid out at the
start of this segment I'll suggest that
training with bands should and does uh
improve jump height and Explosive
Performance likely to a greater extent
than just training with straight weight
would
um which makes sense you match the
strength and resistance curves better
you build more strength through a longer
total percentage of the range of motion
you're training through uh and that
should help you exert Force through the
floor through a larger total range of
motion before your feet leave the ground
so you're not just strong at the bottom
you're strong through that entire range
of motion and that should be beneficial
for Explosive Performance
um like I said all of this stuff uses
bands uh rather than chains and it's all
mostly just looking at Jump performance
so I assume that these are probably
generalizable findings like I assume
that uh if you subbed out bands for
chains it would still be beneficial
because you're still matching strength
Curves in the same way like what they
accomplished with bands in these studies
you can also accomplish with chains uh I
don't see a reason why binging with
bands or doing deadlifts with bands
wouldn't or chains wouldn't have similar
effects through those ranges of motion
and general movement patterns like
um you know if you're trying to build
explosive hip hinging strength like dead
lifting with accommodating resistance
should be pretty good we just don't have
research on it
um
but yeah so I assume these findings
generalize I just don't know for sure
another note is that the gains and
explosiveness in these studies were were
pretty specific so I I made specific
note of talking about the gains in
vertical jump performance uh and the
various sorts of jump tests you do mimic
the mechanics of squatting pretty well
but uh several of these studies also
looked at gains in Sprint performance or
gains in Agility Test performance uh and
for those measures uh training with
bands didn't seem to be more beneficial
than training with straight weight once
again like with one rep max strength it
wasn't that it was less beneficial than
training with straight weight it still
worked
um there just wasn't like in additive
additional benefit so
you know like it it
seems like maybe training with bands
will help you jump higher but might not
actually like improve Sprint performance
or change of Direction performance uh to
a greater extent than training with
straight weight which again to be very
clear means it's still good it's just
not better uh and then
finally uh for for loading
recommendations I think that
um
I think that the the three studies were
training with bands worked are probably
a pretty good starting point so in in
all three of those studies uh the amount
of band tension used was equal to about
30 to 40 percent of one RM uh replacing
an amount of straight weight resistance
equal to about 15 to 20 percent of one
RM so that that seems to be a pretty
good starting point so for example like
if you're one rep max squat is 100 kilos
and a workout would typically involve
squatting with 80 kilos for sets of five
you could instead do 60 kilos with 40 or
yeah 60 kilos with 40 kilos of band
tension or 65 kilos with 30 kilos of
band tension so the average resistance
throughout the range of motion would
would average out to the 80 kilos you
you'd be otherwise training with but
that should help match your the
resistance curve of the exercise with
your strength curve a little bit better
by again subbing out about 30 to 40
percent one rep max amount of resistance
with with bands or chains
um
and then also just as kind of a final
party note is intent matters uh intent
matters a lot with with any power
training whether you're whether you're
using accommodating resistance or just
training with straight weight
um you want to really be trying to
aggressively accelerate the bar as much
as possible through as much of the range
of motion as possible which I'll also
note is just another benefit of training
with accommodating resistance like if if
you're doing explosive bench press with
just the bar
at lockout the bar has to come to a stop
like if you have any reasonable amount
of load on the bar
you don't want the bar to leave your
hands that's dangerous like that's
that's bad and so a a decent percentage
at the end of the concentric is going to
be spent just decelerating the bar like
you're not actively trying to push
through lockout
um
because if you did the bar would either
leave your hands or there would just be
like so much inertia in the bar it would
like pull your back up off of the bench
that's happened to me [ __ ] up the rest
of the set not good you don't want that
going on similar with squats like if you
really try to accelerate all the way
through the concentric with straight
weight as you would if you were jumping
guess what's going to happen you're
gonna jump and like jump squats exist
but if you're you know if your heels
leave the ground or the bar comes up off
your shoulders a little bit with like 70
percent of one RM especially if you're
not ready for it that could be a little
bit hazardous one of the one of the
benefits of bands and chains is just
since the weights getting heavier and
heavier as you proceed through the
concentric you can just actively
accelerate through a larger portion of
the concentric before you have to
decelerate their lockout so that's good
and and also I mean especially with
bands
I don't know exactly why it feels
different than chains but like it does
like but when bands hit you they hit you
hard uh and like on squat they try to
slingshot you through the floor
um so I think like I think like a
low-key benefit of of power training
with bands is just like they sort of
force you to be really really aggressive
with every rep because
if you don't if you don't generate
velocity out of the hole like when they
hit you you're gonna feel it
um but yeah for for any power training
whether you're training with bands or
chains or just straight weight uh intent
matters like you you really want to try
to accelerate the bar as aggressively as
possible through as much of the range of
motion as possible but uh like I
mentioned bands and chains do help you
facilitate doing that just just based on
how they they change the resistance
curve yeah this is not directly related
uh to vertical jump and you know power
and things like that but I will say uh
covid related gym shutdowns completely
change my relationship with bands uh for
the longest time I was like oh those
those things are kind of a pain in the
ass to set up and and all this stuff and
and then covet hit and Man Without bands
I don't know how I would have gotten
through that as a person who lives and
as a as a a coach yeah like who man uh
bands really came through when I needed
them and I will forever be appreciative
so yeah chains and bands are always
going to be on the good side for me
chains because they're very cool and
badass and bands because when you're in
a pinch especially if you're training at
home uh they they really do expand what
you can do oh for sure one one other
thing I'll note not related to improving
explosiveness gem performance whatever
but just kind of like a a low-key
benefit especially of training with
chains
um and especially for folks who've been
Lifting for kind of a long time and are
like maybe sort of beat up uh so like I
mentioned with the Anderson study for
strength development for power
development you don't want to like fully
invert that resistance curve where now
instead of being hard at the bottom easy
at the top it becomes easy at the bottom
hard at the top like that that's
probably not the best way to set them up
purely for improving performance but uh
if you maybe have achy hips or achy
shoulders uh and you get some like range
of motion related discomfort on like
bench press where
you know if if you're if you have pretty
heavy weight on the bar your shoulders
just your shoulders or elbows just
really don't like you much specifically
at the bottom of of the press uh but you
also don't want to just take 70 of the
weight off the bar and just train light
all the time like that's not fun you
don't want to do it uh something you can
do which like I've done and I know a lot
of older lifters do this
um is you can just put a shitload of
chains on the bar so now like the bench
is easy at the bottom where where maybe
your shoulders aren't quite as happy
with you but it just like gets hard and
heavy as you press it so you can still
feel heavy weight in your hands you can
still like really exert yourself not
have to do like 40 reps per set with a
super low load but still
um you know give give some of those soft
tissues that aren't super happy with you
a little bit of a break from the from
the really heavy loading
um that that's another just like very
nice thing you can you can unlock with
accommodating resistance